trong ngày emy chi thống bay, các chi huy quân đội thay lan và càng buổi chia đã tổ chức nhiều của gặp tại bên dưới,
thống nhất thực hiện là được bản và không điều động thêm được lợt.
Tại khu cụng trong thông, tư lần quân khu hai thay lan và phó tư lần quân khu đúng các buổi chia đã thống nhất,
bản nội dùng tránh trong đó có cao càng kết nường bản nếu là tất, không nổ dùng bởi giản thường không tăng viện hai điều trình bình xếp.
Hoài ra hai nước sẽ phó hợp poi hướng thị thay và thông bình thành lập nhóm điều phối gồm bốn người mối bên để xử tình hộ phas xin đông thời cho chỉ đạo từ cô họp quy bán bây giờ chung ngày 1 thật tham.
Các cô hội đàn tương tựa cùng diễn ra dưới quân khu một và quân khu hai của thay lan với lên lợt quân khu ba và quân khu năm của càng buổi chia.
Tất cả đều nhất chỉ thực hiện là đủ các điều khoảng tương tự.
Fia cáp uống chia tổng kết nội dùng các cô họp của bà điểm vui chỉ lệnh bắn tăng cường linh lạc và cùng giả quân sự cố.
Giờ chứ hai bên cũng thống nhất không chính khai quân giọc của vực viên giời trình chấp.
Chờ rau rau rau trình năm ngày giữa hai nước khiến ín nhất bằng mệt tạm.
Ở thức mạng và hơn bà trong miệng người phải xấu tán khỏi có cụi bình dởi.
Ngày hôm tà thống bây, hai bên đã thảo thật nương bản vô được kiện sau cuộc hội đàn tạm mà là xia với sự chung dán từ thủ tương mà là xia,
hôm, anh hoa, hiber hiệm, khiến tình hình tạm bên dởi đả dân đồ định trở lại.